[Musique]
je mangerai cette souris pour mon dîner
mais cela me rappelle une histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver dernier fut excessivement froid
tous les étangs furent gelés pendant
trois mois et les canards dur
d'apprendre à patiner
cependant malgré cette froidure les
parents des petites allées tous les
jeudis à la foire il partait de bon
matin et ne rentrer que tard le soir
nous rentrerons pas la nuit
comme d'habitude en attendant c'est vous
qui gadré la maison c'est une marque de
confiance que nous vous donnons
souvenez-vous surtout de n'ouvrir à
personne quand vous prie ou qu on vous
menace
[Musique]
je n'ai pas trop tôt que ces gens s'en
aillent
j'ai une faim je vais encore plus fait
lire qulité doit être à cause du froid
alors heureusement l'hiver tout le monde
reste ensemble
c'est donc bien plus difficile de se
nourrir à la nature est bien mal
organisé
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je disais ils sont tous
enfermés et bien au chaud à par
l'égoïsme de ckac sports je pouvais
essayer de convaincre un mouton de
sortir je suis sûr qu'il refusera salué
sans rien n'égale que joueur de faim et
en plus je me suis foulé une pâte en
courant après un lapin vais pas de
chance en ce moment où les jolies
petites filles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi non plus alors pourquoi il est on
parce que nous sommes seulement 2 quand
on est deux on ne s'amuse pas bien on ne
peut pas jouer à la roulette par exemple
c'est vrai gnagna la bombe placée rue
régna la couronne malades marié des
trois pièces par les plus forts
qu'est-ce que vous dis je vous dis
bonjour il ne fait pas chaud dehors ça
parce vous savez ce qu'il est roule avec
ses oreilles pointues et aux poils
hérissés dans tous les sens c'est le
loup le loup oui il faut avoir fait
toutes ces petites filles sont jolies et
elle semble aussi bien gentille je
n'aurais jamais le courage de les manger
qu'est ce que je viens de dire est ce
qui m'arrive
j'ai l'impression jeu devient bon c'est
bien ça je deviens bon je suis bon jeu
c'est agréable d'être bon mais alors de
quoi vais-je me nourrir si je ne peux
plus manger d'enfants tant pis on verra
bien ceux-ci bon d'être bon les portes
ont bien fermé
je crois que vous voulez vous j'ai froid
et j'ai une passe qui me fait bien mal
mais je vais vous dire surtout que je
suis devenu bon et alors
alors vous pourriez m'ouvrir la porte
j'entrerai me chauffer à compter du
fourneau et on passerait l'après midi
ensemble comme il a la voix douce il ne
faut pas s'y fier allez vous on vous
êtes là nous ce n'est pas pour vous
renvoyez mais nos parents nous ont
dépendu d'ouvrir la porte
je suis victime d'un préjugé on raconte
beaucoup d'histoires sur le look
il ne faut pas croire tout ce que l'on
raconte
je ne suis pas méchant du tout c'est
tout de même bien mieux que les fois mal
à l'impact il c'est vrai que l'air bien
gentil je ne me dis pas rappelle-toi le
loup et l'agneau la nounou n'avait
pourtant rien fait ma soeur a raison et
là vous avez mangé l'agneau que j'ai
mangé lequel vous allez démangeait
plusieurs bassins du jury naturellement
où j'en ai mangé plusieurs je ne vois
pas mal vous en mangez bien vous ya
encore la montée du gigot ce n'est pas
la même chose je ne vois pas la
différence
allons je vous voyez bien que je ne suis
pas méchant joue vraiment l'importance à
sira en rond autour du fourneau et je
vous raconte
près d histoire depuis je prends que je
rôde au travers des bois et que je cours
sur les plaines vous pensez si j'en
connais rien qu'en vous racontant ce qui
est arrivé l'autre jour aux trois lapins
de la litière je vous préviens refuser
l'entrée il a mangé des agneaux
baghdatis est mourant de faim
il a quel âge et des pannes d'été ça
c'est el manouzi aux pommes de terre à
ton image bon move on lui non on a
oublié quelque chose quoi dont le petit
chaperon rouge alors un peu du petit
chaperon rouge si vous voulez bien c'est
vrai j'ai mangé le petit chaperon rouge
mais j'ai eu bien du remords si c'était
à refaire on dit ça et puis ça fait bien
longtemps que je voulais manger c'était
un péché de jeunesse et à tout péché
miséricorde et puis tous les ennuis que
j'ai eu à cause de cette petite faune
est même allé jusqu'à dire que j'allais
commencer par manger la grand-mère que
le monde est méchant
je vous demande un peu mangé une
grand-mère sèche comme un frigo quand
j'avais sous la patte une petite fille
bien fraîche 1
laumond vient encore à la bouche
si vous aviez tant que ça ne vous
viendrait pas la bouche
pardonnez moi ce n'est pas ma faute
c'est une mauvaise habitude de famille
ne cherche pas des excuses vous mangez
des petites filles
un point c'est tout mais puisque je vous
jure
non non non plus à passer votre chemin
vous réchauffer en courant c'est tout de
même un peu fort c'est à vous dégoûter
d'être honnête on n'a pas le droit le
décourager les bonnes volontés comme
vous le faites et vous pouvez vous dire
que si je re manche de l'enfant ce sera
votre faute ou la région veut l'ouvrir
c'est moi qui suis la plus raisonnable
je peux même la plus notable arrêté
adieu le mieux m'en allais connaître le
sujet d'une querelle entre vous tu vois
quelle délicatesse il faut reconnaître
[Musique]
loupé
ne vous mêlez pop venez vous réchauffer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon dieu comme c'est bon d'être assis au
coin du feu
il n'y a vraiment rien de meilleur que
la vie en famille
je l'avais toujours pensé et maintenant
je vais vous raconter les histoires que
je vous ai promis je vais commencer par
l'histoire de la taupe qui avait trouvé
une paire de lunettes
il leur raconta aussi l'histoire du
lapin qui vivait dans un autre forme est
celle de l'écureuil qui avait le vertige
ensuite il leur chante à compeyre
guillery avec une belle voix de basse
il est peut-être un petit homme qui
s'appelait guilleux ricard avis ils s'en
foutent à la chasse à la chasse aux
perdrix calavi titicaca bibard champ de
calabar compères guillory de l'era tu te
les rats tu te les ratures mûri
enfin une jouèrent à toutes sortes de
jeux si ali mais que je dus me réfugier
sur le haut d'une armoire pour ne pas
être bousculé la joie pris fin vers le
soir quand il fallu songer au départ du
loup non les parents c'est trop
raisonnable
ils ne comprendront jamais que le loup
ait pu devenir bon oui il vaut mieux ne
pas tarder tu reviendras jeudi prochain
et pourquoi tu te souviens de nous
mettons vraiment
[Musique]
bonjour les enfants j'avais été
saint-louis maman que ça alors vous avez
dû vous ennuyer que tu as et visa qu'est
ce que tu as à renifler comme ça une
odeur bizarre aussi une sorte d'odeurs
de loups je ne peux rien sentir je suis
enrhumé comment pouvez vous sentir une
odeur de nous s'il nous a démontré dans
la cuisine il nous aurait mangé toutes
les deux c'est vrai ça il n'y avait pas
songé je n'ai pas vraiment peur ce n'est
pas vraiment de sa mission
c'est incroyable ce bon peu tu entendre
on dirait que vous avez oublié
l'histoire du petit chaperon rouge assez
bavardé mettez-vous à table
lucio ne se sont pas passées du tout
comme vous pourriez le lunar changement
vous le promets il n'allait pas changer
les commandes d'une grand mère tous deux
buts avant de déjeuner d'une petite
fille gavray ch
et puis c'est une vieille histoire un
peu chez nous à tout péché miséricorde
le loup n'est plus ce qu'il était vous
êtes deux têtes folles loup sera
toujours un loup il n'y a pas d'espoir
qui s'améliore et si un loup venez me
dire qu'ils ne mangent que des noisettes
jeu la sommerait tout de même mais bien
sûr les petites ne crurent pas leurs
parents d'ailleurs aucun enfant ne crois
jamais ses parents et en attendant le
jeudi suivant elle pense air tellement à
leur nouvel ami qu'elle jouait tout le
temps au loup vous connaissez
naturellement ce jeu vous y avez tous
jouer
[Musique]
marine est posée la question autant de
fois qu'il était nécessaire au loup pour
passer lui la une
toutes les pièces de son harnachement
depuis ses chaussettes jusqu'à son grand
sabre alors il se jetait sur elle et l'a
dévoré mais comme tout finit par arriver
le jeudi suivant arrive à avant de se
rendre chez ses amis le loup passe un
bon moment à laver son museau et à ce
lui ce trait le poil tu fais une
toilette ya minutieuse en quel honneur
je vais voir deux amis dans toute la
plaine
il n'y a pas de petite fille qu'ils
soient plus rose et plus blonde je n'ai
pas le plaisir de les connaître mais je
suis sûr qu'elles sont aussi bien à
droite du et bien attendre de toi
imbéciles voilà comment on bâtit une
réputation
je ne mangerai pas un cheveu des amis
[Musique]
parent
bonjour boulot
[Musique]
bon
tu sais tu as bien raison nous parlons
ne veulent pas que tu puisses être bon
et pourtant on a bien défendu a loué la
maison était très actuel on a parlé de
deux temps ça ne m'étonne pas
si je vous disais que tout à l'heure le
sanglier lui même nous dans les bois
yahoo via toutes sortes de bêtes avec
ton n'aura pas pas non au printemps vous
n'aurez rien à craindre dans les bois
d'ici là j'aurai si bien prêt chez les
compagnons de la forêt que les plus
hargneux seront devenus doux comme des
filles
tenez pas plus tard qu'avant-hier j'ai
rencontré le renard qui venait de
saigner tout un poulailler
je lui ai dit que ça ne pouvait plus
continuer comme ça qu'il fallait changer
de vie et savez vous ce qu'il m'a
répondu loup
je ne demande qu'à suivre ton exemple et
quand j'aurai eu le temps d'apprécier
toutes tes bonnes oeuvres
je ne tarderais plus à me corriger
voilà ce qu'il m'a répondu tout renard
qu'il est à quoi allons-nous jouer le
jeu du loup était nouveau pour le loup
ont ils ont expliqué les règles tout
naturellement il fut désigné pour être
le loup il se cacha alors sous la table
[Musique]
je mets mon garçon
pas nous quelle honte appétissante petit
job
qu'est ce que tu dis je dis je je mets
ma culotte je je je mets mes bretelles
de ses petites jambes poterie tant pis
je ne peux pas résister je sors du bois
et le loup ne fit qu'une bouchée des
deux petites on peut tirer de
l'événement au moins trois moralité
d'abord que nous sommes peu de choses
ensuite qu'à force de jouer à un jeu on
finit par y croire
enfin que les petites filles ne doivent
pas jouer avec le loup les grandes
filles non plus d'ailleurs
heureusement et contre toute
vraisemblance cette histoire se termine
à bien quand il lui dévorer les deux
petites le loup le plus en année car ils
ne savaient pas ouvrir les portes et en
rentrant les parents l'urca lui ouvrir
le ventre pour délivrer leurs deux
filles
naturellement les parents voulu en
profiter pour tuer le loup mais les
petites intercédait pour lui bien
qu'elles fussent peiné qu'il les eut
manger
[Musique]
et le loup s'en alla le coeur plein de
remords et le ventre recousue avec de la
ficelle
[Musique]
promet nous de ne plus manger de petites
filles je vous le jure
si j'en vois je me sens vrai tu crois qu
il tiendra parole
sûrement peut-être